griffin jacks making this his 13th start
of the season three and four with a six
seven five
breaking ball bounced weekly up the
third baseline
and which way have they called it i
think they called that a fair ball and
that's going to be an infield hit for
george springer
that's rolled up the middle gordon is
there flipping the second that takes
care of the lead-off infield single no
score after a half a good inning for
driven jack manoa making his 19th start
of the season first ever start against
the minnesota twins he picked up his
seventh win last time out of tampa bay
against a raise
up the middle and the lefty gets a base
hit a rise on the first pitch bounces
one up the middle
missing inside it's ball four and a good
start to the inning with a single and
now a walk two men aboard for polanco
swinging bunt
and polancos retired runners move up two
in scoring position now for donaldson
and he gets him a fastball up and in a
swing and a miss for out number two
one two
and he got him manoa strikes out kepler
and after the first two twins reach they
can't score against the big righty
two-two
breaking ball popped up shallow in left
field back goes to shortstop gordon he
reaches out and he can't make the play
neither can cave coming in from left and
the blue jays have their second hit of
the afternoon a blue base hit the
opposite way for corey dickerson not
going
and it swung on and popped up shallow
center field and this one is going to
drop in back to back bloop singles for
the blue jays boy the baseball gods are
on their side in the early going here
today aren't they yeah they got this
short game working so far so the can the
blue jays take advantage of some good
fortune here in the second inning a
couple of blue pits first and second one
out for danny jansen
02 is lifted in the air and well hit
deep left center field gone
danny jansen with a three-run homer and
buck that's a couple of bloops and a
blast for the blue jays to take a three
to nothing lead in the second
half swing thought he went he did
bringer's gone but the blue jays get a
couple of pop fly singles and then a big
fly it's three nothing
there's jay cave over his last ten
three nothing toronto bottom two garber
at second sono at first twins left two
on the first and the pitch flair to
right field that's going to land to base
it garber races around third he will
score miguel will go to third base no
throw there so cave off the end of the
bat dumps the change up into right
drives in his 13th run snaps a note for
10 and it's a 3-1 toronto lead
he did jam him get a ground ball
to second one on to first for the double
play well done buck well done alec manoa
big double play and the twins get just
the one
swing and a miss and manoa strikes out
buxton one down polanco dribbled one
between the mound and home plate
advanced the runners but the twins
didn't
get a base or didn't get a run now in
the center field and now pass the diving
dickerson alanka will hold up with a
single right off the end of the bat and
polancos are born with a one out single
and a fastball grounded to shore to
beshet to simeon one do they have time
to turn two yes they do
another big double play another inning
ending double play three one blue chase
at the end of three garbage now 30 years
old
the o2 swing and a miss got him with a
slider a strikeout for manoa that's
number five on the afternoon two up and
two down in the fourth inning facing
sono with the bases empty
a high fly to left field
going back is dickerson
and off the wall cenota second and he'll
go into there
into second base with a double just
missing a home run ceno added second two
down and again the 3-2 and a swing and a
miss got him with a slider to put him
away and another good job to get out of
it by alec manoa seven fly ball outs for
griffin jacks today here's george
springer and springer sends the ball to
left field this is well head and it's
gonna go
george springer with a home run for the
second consecutive game and it is four
to one blue jays and now buxton who has
walked and struck out with the passcode
and a 3-2 here's the ball heading into
left-center field fairly well
dickerson long run and that ball is
going to be gone hey byron buxton two
out solo homer
twigs now trail four to two
another one two pitch and he got him
beautiful back door breaking ball
polanco knew it and the inning is over
but the buxton home run has made it a
two-run game
wow and an awkward swing by donaldson
manoa three sliders to strike him out
and fighting the sun and dropping the
ball is espinal looking right up into
the sun not used to being out there that
much he's a third baseman by trade but
that was one that even hernandez may
have had a tough time with here comes
tim meza to try to get the left hand
hitting nick gordon and end the sixth
inning
and now meza gets gordon a huge out to
strand a couple of runners
end of six and it is still the blue jays
four and the twins two three and one on
springer with a rudder at second and two
down in the seventh inning the 3-1 to
springer
and he will take a walk and that's
that's a good job of passing the baton
right there that he didn't go after that
borderline pitch willing to take the
walk and turn it over to marcus simeon
there strike three simeon upset couple
of walks are left aboard it's still a
4-2 game rent rooker is on as a pinch
hitter for jake cave to begin the bottom
of the seventh
swing and a miss a good start here mesa
strikes out rooker how many big spots
has meza been in this year and how many
times has he gotten the job done here's
another one right here he ties up a rise
and strikes him out for the second out
of the inning december's been terrific
comes into a situation where he's facing
a right-handed hitter with two outs and
nobody on his 68th appearance of the
season and he'll make you take some
funky swings
he got him a high fastball simber
strikes out buxton and it's through
seven now at target field still 4-2 blue
jays
fly ball to left field
and rooker can't find it
he lost it in the sun so it's happened
in both ways and bechet's at second
let's see if the blue jays can take
advantage of the gift the oscars for
three on three fly ball outs
lace down the left field line a fair
ball this will easily get beshette home
hernandez into second with an rbi double
and it's five to two four man outfield
for kepler and so he just grounds one up
the middle
and we've seen infield shifts for kepler
where there's been somebody standing
there but you can't have more than nine
people out on the field and so you try
to take something away but you give up
something else and kepler's aboard
one-on-one
deep to the right field corner
this might be trouble
off the wall
kepler to third
and he'll be held there garber to second
with a double and now with the tying run
coming to the plate with two down in the
eighth inning the blue jays will turn it
over to jordan romano who is pitching
for the first time since tuesday 02.
sliders strike three called and romano
gets his man
end of eight in minneapolis blue jays
five twins two
one two on the way and he got him swing
and a miss romano strikes out a rise and
the blue jays pick up a much needed
victory beating the twins
five to two this afternoon ensuring that
when they take the field tuesday they'll
be a game out of a playoff spot
you